So would you use commonsense reasoning to design an agent that could answer
Raven's progressive matrices? Here you might make two connections. First you
could connect primitive actions of agents, to primitive transformations in
these matrices. Different problems could be composed out of a finite set of
possible transformations. What would those primitive transformations be?
And what would the action frames involved in each transformation look like?
Second, you might connect those individual primitive actions to
higher level transformations. What would your primitive transformations be?
And what common higher level transformations are possible?
What primitive actions would result in those higher level transformations? And
how would composing these like this, actually help you
solve Raven's progressive matrices? In a way that you couldn't do otherwise?